hey guys I'm here with my lovely wife
Karen and we are going to make the most
incredible recipe for bread you've been
waiting for this this is the ultimate
bread and there's no flour no gluten no
bad stuff so how do you do this Karen
it's so easy you're gonna love it so
it's 1 cup of almond flour in my Santa
cup measuring cups it is one cup of
arrowroot flour you use a little
arrowroot here arrowroot is a low
glycemic flour it's made from a root so
it's its small amounts it's okay
arrowroot that's why they call it root
that weren't exactly this doesn't come
out as quickly and then 1/3 cup of
coconut flour and these combined give it
a really neat texture most of the
natural breads out there kind of tastes
terrible like they're calm and it's like
a sponge cake like bark yeah then we're
going to just do 1 teaspoon of salt and
that's it for the dry ingredients mix it
up
very very so smells really good already
and then you go on to beast which is
also very simple so now we're going to
do the yeast portion we're going to pour
in wanted a quarter cup of warm water
between 105 and 110 degrees and the
temperature really is important if it's
too cold or too hot the yeast will not
do its thing we're going to add two
teaspoons of what sort of maple syrup
that's for the that's the food for the
yeast so it's not going to be a plug
because they're yeast of anything though
and produce carbon dioxide now we're
going to take two teaspoons of instant
dry yeast and this equals one packet one
packets usually two teaspoons if you're
using the smaller packages now is this
delicate I mean like is it could you
actually mess this up you can mess it up
and I have messed it up I used water
that was way too hot and what's supposed
to happen now is the yeast is going to
eat this the maple syrup what any of the
true is the water well like I said 105
210 okay and then the yeast is going to
eat the maple syrup and it's gonna push
out a little gases but that's gonna foam
up and that's actually what's going to
make your so you basically keep it there
and then you're waiting ten minutes okay
alright I just don't want to give you
any opinions because you have the
opinion wasn't in the rest your opinion
wasn't in the recipe right is that a
subtle hint it's subtle is it subtle is
it subtle enough right okay for ten
minutes there okay this is wait okay
really if you stand and look at it
you'll see little bubbles coming up it's
like little yeast fireworks it is alive
that's the really cool thing it is
totally alive and
they're so what's happening is the yeast
is eating the maple syrup and literally
pushing out little excreting little
gases and that's what helps your bread
rise yeah that's amazing mm-hmm and this
is exactly what's supposed to happen so
that's what's good
uh-huh we're doing good the key is the
temperature oh yeah but also your yeast
if your yeast isn't any good anymore you
can have the perfect temperature water
and it won't do that okay so after about
10 minutes your yeast is going to be
beautiful and foamy it's done it's
eating of all that maple syrup isn't it
yeah so now what we're going to do is
we're going to add two tablespoons of
psyllium and one-and-a-half tablespoons
of ground chia psyllium is kind of like
a fiber yeah and you know we get whole
Chia and then we have one little coffee
grinder that we use just for spices and
seeds and stuff like that so you're
going to let it sit in there for two or
three minutes and it's going to get
really gelatinous and thick and then
you're going to whisk it so now you're
going to cut this because we have to
wait all right so this has been sitting
for just two or three minutes in it it
got gelatinous lucious so now we're just
going to stir it all in
make sure it's all whisked in quisque
alright good now just going to put this
in our dry ingredients
and mix it up and you are going to see
this become it's amazing you know this
is one of those things that people been
trying to figure this out for yours
you can't really find a good bread
recipe without the wheat so we found I
was so surprised how well this turned
out I did find this online I'm not sure
what we've changed but I appreciate
people who have done all the research to
figure out especially the chant and the
psyllium because that's amazing now it's
going to look gloopy like this and
you're literally going to need it just
for one minute yeah I think what happens
is that you have them you don't have the
gluten so gluten is like glue and so you
have that I think probably combination
chia seed some of the fiber tends to act
like glue which is perfect because we
can do that all day long
yep now you can take this out of the
bowl I'm just leaving it in the bowl can
you make a pizza crust with that like I
can I used to do that I used to do it
okay so now look we'll have this
beautiful beautiful Bowl
I mean pool ball of dough okay so now
I'm going to put it in a slightly
smaller bowl rinse my hands really quick
and I have a damp towel I'm going to put
it over my bread and excuse me dr. Berg
now I'm going to put it in my warm space
which is just not a cold space oops
and for an hour we're going to let it
rise okay so after you've had your yeast
rising in some warm place for an hour
you're going to take it out now I don't
have my oven on my ovens off but it's
the warmest place so I just put the bowl
in there take it out damp cloths is no
longer down that's what it looks like it
did rise it should double and there you
go that's just like it is dough it's
beautiful as a matter of fact now what
you're going to do is cut it in half
because you can make it too
you want a big one you can leave it but
then you're gonna make it into a round
rule what is a bull anyway bull it's
just round bread I had to look it up
myself okay so now that's that alright
now to get it golden brown the new trick
do this squares that's second yeah so an
egg wash it's just an egg yolk with a
tiny little bit of water a teaspoon of
water and you're just gonna wash your
little boo that's going to make it nice
and brown and crispy on the outside like
a sourdough
and then another thing just to give it a
little bit of a touch is you can do a
little crisscross pattern with a knife
you could
so little it's going to give it a little
something now
the original recipe said use a stone I
don't have a stone what I do is I like
to put it on hot pan I use parchment
bring this over here normally I would
just carry the loaves over to the oven
but for this literally put this on hot
parchment and on the pan and that's it
it's going to go into the oven
unfortunately our oven light isn't
working right now so you'll see that
when it comes out okay it's time to take
the bread out of the oven let's take a
look Wow now we've made a few loaves
this is why it didn't turn into one loaf
in the oven come look that's serious
bread we can't touch that until it's
cool inside because it'll be chewy nope
so check the services this is a great
way to eat butter it is a great way to
eat butter mmm it toasts beautifully it's
better than bread better than well it is bread